you guys think that you'll be able to
overtake the us
like you have the uk that is our dream
in life yeah we hope so
i mean it's going all right so far but
um
yeah that's the aim in life to just take
over america
and the world that was little mix singer
jessie nelson back in 2013.
fast forward to 2020 and she's announced
that she's leaving after nine years with
the girl group
the 29 year old singer shared the news
in a lengthy statement on instagram
monday
revealing in the emotional post that the
job has taken a toll on her
quote to all my mixers the past nine
years in little mix has been
the most incredible time of my life we
have achieved things i
never thought possible she went on to
thank her fans for making her feel like
the luckiest girl in the world
adding that she'll never ever forget it
we just love it it's so fun
the truth is recently being in the band
has really taken a toll on my mental
health i find the constant pressure of
being in a girl group and
living up to expectations very hard
there comes a time in life when we need
to reinvest in taking care of ourselves
rather
than focusing on making other people
happy and i feel like now
is the time to begin that process jessie
said the decision to leave the group was
made with a heavy heart
but now she plans on spending some time
with the people she loves
and doing things that make her happy she
wrapped up her message thanking her
bandmates
jade perry and leanne quote i hope that
you'll continue to fulfill
all of your dreams and keep on making
music that people love
[Music]
the news of jesse's departure comes a
month after multiple outlets reported
that she would be taking an extended
hiatus from little mix due to private
medical reasons
the uk native has been notably absent
from a few appearances with the band
including the mtv european music awards
on november 8th
but jesse's bandmates insists it's all
love
posting monday to instagram that it is
an incredibly sad time
but they are fully supportive of her
decision quote we love her very much
and agree that it is so important that
she does what is right for her mental
health
and well-being
[Music]
the group was formed in 2011 on the
british version of the
new
x
factor
e.t was with the group two years later
and it was clear
the ladies were a solid unit is there
ever a point where
one of you wants to sing the solo and
the other one is like
hey that's my solo no no all that songs
are really even though evenly split
and usually we know like as soon as we
go in the studio when we hear the song
or
we're writing who's going to sing what
because we all got completely different
voices so we always know what who suits
what and in 2017
jessie told et they owe all their
success to their mixers
we love our fans so much and to be an
event like this with them all here is
just incredible
because you guys are crazy our fans over
here are mental but in the best way
[Music]
possible